x =2.
Now we're adding another step to
our process of solving equations.
Just a note I've written
that steps to solve for
x but this applies for any variable.
So it can be x or it can be a or
b or c or anything you want.
So the step that we need to
add is actually something that
we should do before these other two
steps, so we'll just move that down.
So now the first step that we need to
do before these other two steps is
we need to clear fractions by
multiplying both sides of the equation
by a common denominator.
Three, six and two all go into six.
So six is the least common
denominator we should use.
We will multiply both sides by six.
Distributing six within
the parentheses we get six
thirds x minus six over
six equals six over two.
We'll simplify this a bit.
Six thirds is two so 2x.
And six over six is one so
2x- 1 = 6/2, that's 3.
Now we can get to our next
step which is to add or
subtract to get the variable term alone.
So we need to add one to both sides and
we get 2x + 0 = 3 + 1.
That's really 2x = 4.
And now we can multiply or divide so
the coefficient on the variables is one.
We'll divide both sides by two.
We cross out the two and
we get x = 4 / 2.
4 / 2 is just 2.
So x = 2.